let's talk a little bit more about just
a wacky First 48 Hours of 2024
presidential campaign for former
ambassador to the United Nations former
South Carolina Governor Nikki Haley
really a very bad first couple of days
day one of her campaign videos surface
wherein Nikki Haley defends the
Confederate flag and wrongly claims that
states can just choose to secede from
the United States day two which was
yesterday Nikki Haley holds her first
campaign event and plays the exact same
type of identity politics that
Republicans claim to be against I'm a
woman I'm a minority I thought
Republicans told us identity politics is
bad or is it only bad when the left does
it here she invokes her own
uniqueness racially to claim the
country's not racist which is a really
popular line among Republicans in doing
so not only does she play identity
politics she kind of seems to prove the
country might be racist take a listen to
this Joe and come like say America's
racist
nothing can further from the truth
okay
[Applause]
foreign
people know better
my immigrant parents know better
and take it from me the first minority
female governor in history America is
not a racist country
you know I'm not sure first of all overt
identity politics just the the exact
type of identity politics that they
attack all the time let's put the
hypocrisy aside for a second hypocrisy
knows no bounds at this point with these
people
I don't know that when you say
we elected the first minority woman
governor in 2011 that it's the strongest
evidence that the U.S at least wasn't a
racist country it seems like a little
bit late in the game to be able to make
that case by the time that the country
was hundreds of years old we finally
elected the first minority female
governor which proves there's no race
problem in the United States or gender
problem no woman president ever
first woman VP not until 2020. these are
not particularly compelling data points
to be perfectly honest with you Nikki
Haley continuing to play the same
identity politics that she says is bad
when other people do it saying May the
best woman win I will simply say this
May the best woman win
pretty clever line huh guys
the crowd not exactly reflecting and
saying wait a second I thought we were
supposed to be against that type of
identity Paul no the crowd simply cheers
um one other interesting note she kicked
off this event with a prayer from
extremist Pastor John Hagee I'm not even
going to waste your time with a clip but
I will briefly mention that John Hagee
runs the Cornerstone Church in San
Antonio Texas
extremist lunatic long history of saying
crazy stuff he said Hitler was sent by
God to usher in the state of Israel he
said Hitler was a half-breed Jew he
called the Catholic Church the great
he has said insane things about
abortion and 9 11 all these crazy things
and Nikki Haley started this off by
saying I still want to be Pastor Hagee
when I grow up before I start I've got
to give a shout out to the people who
took the podium by the way plagued with
audio issues the entire event for me
um to Pastor Hagee I still say I want to
be you when I grow up thank you
beautiful and very very muted clapping
at that moment everything about this
event was pathetic humiliating and
hypocritical but there was one really
funny moment from this event which I
want to actually devote a little bit of
time to imagine for a second that you
try logging into your email account only
to find that your password was changed
an hour ago and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and then your credit cards that is what
identity theft is like and it's a
horrible feeling and we dealt with it at
the show not that long ago but now I
have an app called Aura which gives me
much more peace of mind our sponsor Aura
is the all-in-one solution for keeping
your online account safe because Aura
will scan the dark web for your personal
info passwords social security number
and you get fast alerts when they find
something you also get fast alerts about
credit inquiries Aura protects all of
your devices from malware or even
request test the removal of your info
from data broker sites and Aura helps
you manage what your kids can do on
their devices you can restrict certain
apps set screen time limits set Focus
times when you need them off of devices
go to aura.com Pacman to try it free for
seven days your login credentials might
already be floating around out there and
Aura will tell you instantly for free
the link is down below